R
WE INTRODUCE CHARLES?
>> I THINK PEOPLE ARE WONDERING
WHERE CHARLES MIGHT BE.
HE IS MAKING QUITE THE GRAND
ENTRANCE TONIGHT.
>> WHERE IS HE?
>> ON A HORSE.
>> UNOFFICIAL MAYOR OF DALLAS,
TEXAS HAS ARRIVED FROM ALABAMA.
BY WAY THE TNT STUDIOS IT IS THE
CHUCKSTER.
>> YOU HAVE A MAN PULLING YOU ON
THE HORSE?
>> TELL HIM TO LET GO.
>> CHUCK, TELL HIM TO LET GO.
>> I GREW UP IN ALABAMA, I KNEW
HOW TO RIDE A HORSE!
>> THE HAT LOOKS GOOD ON YOU.
LIKE A NATURAL-BORN COWBOY.
>> HE DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A
NATURAL BORN COWBOY.
>> YES, I DO.
>> I HOPE THAT HORSE LIKES LOUD
CROWDS.
>> THAT HORSE HAS A STRONG BACK!
>> THE HORSE IS SAYING, PLEASE
GET THIS GUY OFF ME.
PLEASE.
>> SEE HIM.
THIS IS ALWAYS THE TEST.
>> HE CAN'T RAISE THAT RIGHT TIP
OVER THE HORSE'S HEAD.
>> PLEASE, FALL.
>> YOU CAN'T GET IT OVER.
>> I TOLD YOU.
TELL THE